Này 2,5 tăng sấu tại hà nội, tổng mít thư chủ bình nước tổ lơm đã tiếp quyền vổ trường vụ hải quân hoa ki hùng cao.
Tại người tiếp, tổng mít thư chủ bình nước tổ lơm hoàn lên chuyến tham của quyền vổ trường hùng cao và đàn công tác.
Nhân dịt tham gia trình trình lối tác thái bình dương, bạc bạc thái bình dương hành hùng trăm hay sấu.
PPP hành hùng trăm hay sấu, bánh gia cao ý nghĩa của việc tối trích trình trình hợp tác nhìn đạo và ứng phó kíu trở thiểm tay này,
đại tình hòn trị, đại phương trị nhiều hậu qua nặng nè của chính tranh cũng như tác động của thiên tay này.
Tổng mít thư chủ bình nước cũng chuyển lời tham hỏi tới tổng thống lâu năng tròm và phùn dân.
Đồng thời nhắc lại lời mời tổng thống và phùn dân sớm tham bình năm.
Tổng mít thư chủ tình nước tổ lâm khẳng định Việt Nam luôn có hoa ki là đối tác có tổng quan trọng chính lược hành đầu.
Mong muốn cùng hòa ki tiếp tục trên khai hiệu quả khun cười hợp tác lối tác chính lực tần dẹt.
Nó khoát hệ hai nước phát triển ngày gặn thức chất xấu dọng và nhiều quả.
Nhất chỉ người những bánh giá của tổng mít thư chủ tình nước,
quyền bối trường mung cao trời rằng thật thóc phòng trường đó có hợp tác ăn mình hành hành.
Đóng vai trọng quan trọng cho hòa bình thì vượn của hành nước cũng như ăn mình thật thóc và phát triển ở khu vực.
Ông vầy tòa mong muốn tiếp tục mở giọng hợp tác trọng các lĩnh vực ăn mình hành hành hành.
Nên cáo năng lực hỗ trợ nhìn đạo.
Tấn phó thiên tay và các thách thức chồng của khu vực,
tổng mít thư chủ tình nước tổ làm đề nghỉ hoặc kì tiếp tục rí chỉ và mở giọng các dãng tài động điều sinh.
Già phá bó mình khổ trợ người khuyết tạc,
không các thông tin, kì vật, tìm kiếm và sát định dành tính hại cóm được sĩ Việt Nam.
Tổng mít thư chủ tình nước tổ làm vầy tò tin tưởng quan hệ Việt Nam hoặc kì sẽ tiếp tục phát triển ở đây,
thức chất và hiệu quả.
Đóng góc thích cựt cho khá bình, tạc và phát triển ở khu vực ăn nổ dân.
Thái đình dân.